House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
says he wants to work
on bringing House
Republicans back together
after the conservative Freedom
Caucus sharply
criticized his debt ceiling deal.
But after the concessions
McCarthy made to get the gavel,
can he keep those members
who criticize the debt vote
from trying to remove him as speaker?
You're with me
now is a member of the Freedom Caucus
Congressman Ken Buck of Colorado.
Thank you so much for joining me
this morning.
You I want to make clear
you don't vote to raise the debt limit.
So you
certainly didn't vote on this deal.
But I want to ask you about it
in the context of the Freedom Caucus.
You called the deal
atrocious and yet it passed
by almost 200 votes,
including a majority of Republicans.
President Biden,
I should say, signed the law yesterday.
What does this say
about the power of your colleagues
in the Freedom Caucus at this moment?
Well, first, Dan, if
I may, I
wanted to
correct something that
Jamie Raskin said earlier.
My colleague from Maryland
There is no MAGA group in the house
that wants to make sure that we default.
That's just a talking point.
That is unfair.
There are a lot of people in the house
and a lot of representatives in the House
Freedom Caucus.
I want to make sure
that we don't spend
more money than we have
and that we don't spend ourselves
into a really bad situation.
But I think the House Freedom Caucus,
with a five vote majority in the House,
still retains
a lot of influence in the House.
The key is that we use that influence
in a way
that brings conservative results.
And I think that's
what we tried to do with this case.
And we failed
Honestly, the speaker got Democrats
to vote for this bill
because the bill is
and in fact, more Democrats voted
for this bill.
Republicans This bill is a Democrat bill.
It is a bill
that not only avoided a default,
but also locked in the progressive gains
that the president made
in the last two years.
You said that Speaker McCarthy
should be concerned
about a motion to vacate.
That's when
one member can force a vote on
whether to remove him
from the speakership.
Is that going to happen?
I don't know if a motion to vacate
is going to happen right away.
I do know that Speaker
McCarthy has credibility issues.
He promised
when he was running for speaker
that we would use the 2022
baseline numbers
as the appropriation numbers
for this year
and then went back on that promise
with this particular legislation.
Where he promised
and signed into law the 20, 23 numbers.
So
we continue to see the swamp
the folks in Washington D.C.
who want to spend more money winning.
And we continue to see the folks
who want to spend less money
and really act responsibly losing.
And so I think that
Kevin McCarthy
has an issue in a broader sense.
Well what's going to determine
whether you and
some of your colleagues will actually use
the rule motion to vacate
effectively trying to push them out
Well, I don't think it can
be used by just a few people.
I think there has to be a consensus
in the conference, Republican conference,
and I think there has to be a
really a I applaud
Kevin McCarthy for saying
he wants
to bring people back together again.
Let's see if he does
that in a way that involves spending
responsibly in the future,
because that's really what a lot of us
have to see,
if he's going to regain credibility.
Well,
he doesn't seem all that concerned
about a motion to vacate.
I want you to listen to what he said.
Look, everybody has the ability
to do what they want.
But if you think I'm
going to wake up in the morning
and to be ever worried about that
doesn't bother me.
If someone thinks they have a right to
do it, call the measure
He did show strength.
A majority of the House
Republican Conference
did vote for the deal.
You just told me that it wouldn't happen
unless there was consensus
in the conference based on the vote.
You're not going to get that.
He's going to stay where he is
because he's claiming victory
Well, a lot of people voted for this
because they have other interests
that Kevin McCarthy has assured them of.
But but that doesn't mean
that they are satisfied
with his leadership,
and it doesn't mean
that they're happy
about the fact
that they had to vote for this.
Nancy Pelosi, in her years
and years of being speaker
never once asked Republicans
to vote for the rule,
the a procedural mechanism
that puts the bill on the floor.
Kevin McCarthy in his first five months
had to ask the Democrats
and received 52 votes from the Democrats
to actually have the bill heard.
That's that's really unheard of.
And in shows weakness.
And I think that's the sort of weakness
that Republicans are looking at
and trying to make a determination
whether he will be fit to serve.
Just just one more question on this.
The other side of that coin is
being able to get Democrats
to vote
on a procedural measure that Democrats
almost never vote on
could be seen as a sign of strength
that he is
a speaker who is a constitutional role
for the entire House, not just for
the conservative caucus.
Sure, it could be
considered a sign of strength
to those who are outside the U.S.
House
when when you are forced to get Democrat
to vote on a bill that locks in
President Biden's
progressive agenda and huge
spending increases
which have resulted in inflation,
which have resulted
in really damage to our economy.
You're not strong
in the view of Republicans.
I want to turn to a different topic,
and that is CNN reporting
that federal prosecutor
has obtained an audio
recording of former President Trump
talking about holding on
to a classified document
about a potential U.S.
attack on Iran.
That was after he left office.
You're an elected official.
You know that it is illegal
to take classified documents
and the tape appears to show that he knew
he had those documents.
Do you find
what President Trump
did, the former president, irresponsible
Well, as a
former prosecutor for 25 years,
I think it goes
beyond just irresponsible.
It's a
I don't know if
if anybody has located the document
or there's a copy of the documents
somewhere that can show just what kind of
information and classification
that that document had.
And I don't know
if anybody saw the document.
I know that he was waving some paper,
but I don't know
anybody saw
a document with a stamp on it.
It wouldn't be the first time
that President Trump
has talked about things.
And he may have been illustrating
something, but
it depends on what the testimony is as
to how
severe this is for his criminal case,
if it is found
or if they can prove it at DOJ.
Based on your years as a prosecutor,
did he break the law
and should he be charged with a crime
Well, again,
I am not going to second
guess the prosecutors at DOJ.
I work there.
I have a huge amount of respect for them,
and I'm sure they'll do the right thing.
But I
without knowing,
without seeing the witnesses,
without examining the documents,
it would be irresponsible for me
to suggest that
he should be prosecuted or should not.
You have acknowledged
more broadly
that Donald Trump
is facing some ethical challenges
in his campaign.
In addition
to what
we're talking about,
the classified documents
probe he's under investigation
for election interference in Georgia
for January six.
He's already been indicted in New York.
Would Republicans
be better off with a candidate
who is not facing multiple
criminal investigations
You know, it's interesting.
I think that the multiple investigations
and civil lawsuits that had been brought
almost give
this presidential candidate
and former president credibility.
He keeps saying
that the world is against him
because he's trying to
make these changes.
But does it give at all?
Does he give him credits
that are being taken?
Sorry, forgive me, but you said
I know what you're saying.
It gives him credibility with maybe
with some in the electorate.
But for you, Ken Buck, does it
give him credibility to you?
Well, I have seen him for four years.
I was in the House when he was president.
I voted on his bills.
I voted against his bills.
Sometimes his budgets and whatnot.
So I have seen him personally.
I don't look at the actions
that he has taken
that that are being investigated
as much as his his role
as a former president
and what his policies were.
One last question.
You attended an event for Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
here in Washington in April.
You sat next to him on the House
Judiciary Committee
when he was in the House.
What do you think of his campaign so far?
Do you have advice for him
Yeah, I actually mentioned to him
when we talked
at that event in Washington, D.C.,
My advice is not to try to oust Trump,
Donald Trump.
There is nobody that is
really that operates
in the same area as Donald Trump.
And I think Ron
DeSantis has a strong record
of accomplishment in Florida
when he was dealing with COVID
and some other areas.
And I think those are the things
that he should be running on.
I have not endorsed
Ron DeSantis
and I would go to events for Nikki
Haley or
Tim Scott or others who are friends.
But I do think that that he Ron
should do
his very best
to run on his strong record as governor.
Ken Buck, thank you so much.
I appreciate you coming on this morning.
Thank you.